is the 80s middle of the night yeah and
I see a guy get his arm ripped off what
on a motorcycle
oh my God loses his arm he's in shock
another guy grabs him and you grab the
arm no he got the arm and he's holding
his arm sitting on the curb the woman
who hit him jumped out of her car and
then books it down the street running
yeah I was on my skateboard so I just
followed up followed her oh Mike and the
cops are coming and I helped the cops
find her I go you know right there in
the laundromat so you like 19.
one night Welcome to Hollywood E5 1986.
I love that you gave the cops a hand
also I love you being like you don't
understand I've seen so many accidents
cops I know how this thing
come on